Nicholas Capaldi author of John Stuart
Mill a biography who was he that's a
very good question there are lots of
different answers that can be given one
way of putting it is that he was the
perhaps the most famous British
philosopher of the 19th century he was
the conscience of his time of Victorian
society as a man that had a long and
very famous love affair and to this day
continues to divide people on every
conceivable public policy issue when did
he live he was born in 1806 and died in
1873 in fact it's easy for me to
remember those dates because his father
was born in 1773 and Bill died in 1873
and it's almost impossible to separate
the life of the son from the life of the
father in his lifetime what are the
major things that happened in the world
and Britain Oh Britain went through a
very important change it had to absorb
the Industrial Revolution which led to
changes in every other institution in
British society political cultural
aesthetic Britain also assumed a
position of world leadership not unlike
the kind of influential position that
the United States occupied since the
last half of the 20th century when was
the last time a full biography was
written on John Stuart Mill the last
major biography was by John Peck which
was in 1954 and it's somewhat dated
although it's a very good book because
there's been an enormous amount of mill
scholarship produced since then we also
have the collected works of mill
including seven volumes of of
correspondence and that has made a
tremendous difference in our
understanding of what John Stuart Mill
was all about you probably don't
remember but it's not the easiest
reading in the world even deal how long
you been dealing with Jon Stewart ah
probably twenty-five years started
reading John Stuart Mill when I was in
graduate school made a tremendous
impression on me in fact it was the
first time in my life that a
philosophical book actually spoke to me
rather than simply impressing me with
its profundity and I worked off and on
variety of scholarly issues in mil but
was continually drawn to his life
because I found after reading his
autobiography that I began to understand
the man and the idea is much better once
I understood his life and the way in
which his thought was evolving and what
he was trying to do and so I just
continued to work on it often or until
the opportunity came up to produce a new
now important biography simply because
one hasn't been done for quite some time
and certainly not with the advantage of
all the scholarly work that we have in
the meantime these are always dangerous
question but if he were here today and
lived in this country what politics
would he follow ah I can answer that
question in several ways I mean if we
brought him back from the dead and we
didn't tell him anything that happened
in the meantime or if we brought him
back and filled him in on everything
which took place I think one one hand he
would not be surprised because he had a
certain vision of where Western
civilization was going and its
responsibility for somehow transforming
the world so I think his perception on
the one hand would be that the kind of
position that the United States occupies
and the sort of responsibilities that
are thrust upon it whether it wants them
or not are quite comparable to the sort
of situation in which Britain found
itself in the 19th century I think he
would be pleased by some of the
developments that took place in the
meantime I think he would also be
displeased by the general moral tenor of
society the lack of a kind of moral
consensus that he had hoped to see form
somehow as a result of his own work
what would he call moral though moral
would be people who had strong
convictions that truly respected the
views of each other that were intent
upon trying to find out what the element
of truth was in the view of people with
whom they disagreed I think his
perception of politics today would be
that it's become too partisan and shrill
to use a kind of cliche it's no longer
the practice of gentlemen which is
presumably what he thought it was for a
very large extent in Victorian Britain
there was a kind of culture to which all
these people belonged and it was a
certain sort of understanding
about what you could do and could not do
what areas should be discussed what
areas should not be discussed what the
permissible limits of discussion were
all that seems to be gone now and I
think he would somehow be disappointed
by them you really didn't answer my
question
would he be a Republican or a Democrat
or either neither
I think this position would be that
Republicans and Democrats both embody
the kind of worldview that that he held
that technological progress is
absolutely essential that market
economies are the only way in which
technological project process a project
can proceed that you need something like
democratic government with all kinds of
constitutional guarantees and the rule
of law that beyond that you need a
larger culture which promotes personal
autonomy so from from that point of view
the major political parties pretty much
adhere to the position that mill has has
staked out the differences between
parties of personality and questions of
judgment about how to proceed or in one
area rather than other what'll be really
rather trivial from from his point of
view because the general outline that
they adhere to is the sort of thing that
that he himself advocated in his own
time well you say in the book he didn't
believe in direct mark see he didn't
believe in direct democracy but we don't
really have direct democracy in the US
we obviously have a constitutional
government a republic if you like with
all the guarantees built in to protect
minorities and to promote the notion of
individual rights I think he would
continue to be concerned about the kinds
of problems that direct democracy
creates namely if you have a large mass
of people who are relatively uneducated
and only recently given political rights
and economic opportunities there's a
tendency to want to abuse that in other
words to use government not to protect
rights but to simply extend privileges
that I think would concern him a great
deal on the other hand it does seem to
be the case that even though we argue
about these things nevertheless they're
the limits within which we argue them I
think everybody pretty much agrees what
the limits are
well the where we want to be on the
spectrum might vary from person to
person or party to party
but I would say the the spectrum within
which we argue is the spectrum that he
pretty much laid out well Europeans tend
I think to to see this they tend to kind
of dismiss the differences between
Republicans and and Democrats and
certainly from their point of view those
differences are insignificant compared
to the kind of political differences you
find on the continent of Europe are
there any particular groups in this
country that follow him is like a patron
saint oh not not really not at modern
politics I think he has a number of
followings this is one of the
fascinating things about him there are
people in economics who still take his
economic views seriously there are
people in political theory who read his
political works of rather carefully but
they don't actually pay much attention
to his economic works I think a lots of
people in languages and literature would
read his biography his autobiography and
and his writings on poetry and the arts
etc and would and would take that
serious oh sorry I think you have a kind
of a multiplicity of MIL publics now
rather than rather than one Milic or a
particular group that would identify
itself is as millions in a matter of
speaking we're all millions now so if
you're in the general public and you're
not an intellectual mm-hmm what
difference does it make to know all this
stuff
it makes it makes this kind of
difference one of the things that that
mill was vitally concerned with was
whether ordinary people would come in
the long run to support the kind of
liberal culture that he was that he was
promoting to put it another way the
ideal he had of what it meant to be a
decent human being at one time would it
would have been thought that only
members of the aristocracy or nay lead
could possibly adhere to that mill so
democracy is a threat and his response
to that threat was to promote the idea
that the average person could in fact
become a kind of aristocrat in the best
sense of the term and you did that not
so much by being original but by
thinking your own thoughts and creating
a life for yourself it is in that sense
that mill speaks to every single person
if I can give what might seem a a rather
trite
sample not from Mills life but from our
own if you were to ask most people what
is their favorite Frank Sinatra song
assuming they still listen to Frank
Sinatra the answer would be my way and I
think what that song captured and it's
sort of an analogy with mill is a notion
that I want to be the master of my own
life I want to define who I am I want to
pursue my own ideals and not be
pressured by other by other people
that's what mill advocated and to end to
a very large extent he thought that was
it was possible for every single human
being to achieve that no matter what
their intellect or economic capacity was
and he thought was important that they
did that because the kind of
civilization we've constructed very much
requires everybody to to achieve that
sort of level and all this kind of work
for that in one way or another
however we disagree about which policies
are going to best hasten the the process
in terms of which everybody will be able
to participate what do you do now on a
full-time basis alright I used to teach
philosophy and I still do to some extent
with my main occupation the moment is to
teach business ethics and I as I tell my
former colleagues and philosophy having
solved all the problems in philosophy
I've moved on to the application of what
I've learned to public policy issues and
certainly the world of Commerce today
strikes me as being where all of the
action is where all the major moral and
political issues of the day come up and
and the social issues Commerce has
completely transformed our life Commerce
requires a certain set of values in
order for it to work properly it's
changed the way of workers employers and
employees interact with each other and
all of those were vital concerns to to
mills so in a sense I'm getting an
opportunity at present to apply to a
specific area of the world a lot of what
I think I've learned and understood from
studying the history of ideas and the
sort of ideas that mill was interested
in promoting where do you do this I do
it at Loyola University in in New
Orleans how long have you been there two
years and like mill I fell in love with
a very wonderful person
and commuted for a number of years to
the University of Tulsa until I was able
to get a position at Loyola so on a very
personal level I can identify with some
of the kinds of conflicts he had to go
through and getting his life together
did you marry this person yes I did when
eight years ago although I had to be
reminded that it was eight years because
it seems like yesterday where are you
from originally
um I grew up in Philly but I spent most
of my adult life in New York at the City
University of New York then I spent part
of the 90s in at in Tulsa at the
University of Tulsa but I had done some
visiting in the meantime my visiting
professor at the University of Singapore
spent a year as a visiting professor at
West Point and various foundations and
things of that sort so I've had an
opportunity to travel so you got some
money for this book from the Earhart
foundation yes I did
what's on that's a private foundation
that supports scholars who are working
on various projects but perhaps the most
important thing they do is try to
provide grants for people who are going
into college teaching it's become very
expensive to go to school even even
graduate education these days and if you
don't have you know full scholarship and
some money to live on it's not likely
that you'll be able to pursue graduate
work so a number of people have been
identified as Earhart professors myself
included and we're at 50 different
institutions in the United States we
find promising young men and women that
we think would be ideal not only from an
intellectual but also from a character
point of view to be teachers and
academic leaders in the future and when
we so identify them we recommend them to
the Earhart foundation they provide
grants and we continue to mentor these
students as they go through graduate
school who was Earhart that particular
Earhart I'm embarrassed to say I don't
know but I know there's no relationship
to Amelia Earhart or a lid big Earhart
from Germany I don't think so
the Liberty Fund also was involved in
this yes the Liberty fund is another
private operating foundation founded by
Pierre Goodrich again no relationship to
Goodrich tired Goodrich was a remarkably
successful businessman his far
there'd been a former governor of the
state of Indiana and the most
interesting thing about the Goodrich is
is that they managed to see that the
market was oversold in 1929 so low their
stocks and then bought it back at a much
lower price and they were into every
conceivable thing mining banks whatever
he was also a man interested in ideas
and he thought the idea of Liberty was
in fact the the most important idea in
the history of the world and literally
donated all of his money had no children
to set up an operating foundation where
people can get together and have
conversations about everything under the
Sun whether it's literature or politics
or economics or whatever as long as at
some point or other in the conversation
they tried to relate it to celebrity as
I tried to explain to my students on
occasion it's one of those remarkable
examples of philanthropy that one finds
in America to which there really is no
counterpart in foreign countries people
who amassed a fortune and then donated
for all of these so you know
philanthropic purposes but to donate it
for the study of an idea
indicates to some extent that Goodrich
was not only a generous man but also a
take an eccentric of types again 1806
1806 for 1870 1873 he was what 66 when
he died correct was he accepted where is
he buried today oh he's buried in Avenel
and the South of France along with his
wife Harriet Taylor mill spent a great
deal of time in France in fact at one
point he was probably the person England
most knowledgeable about about French
affairs and he and his wife would
occasionally vacation there and she died
in fact all of their weight too to spend
some time in the South of France in
Italy and she he had to bury her in
Avignon she was perhaps the most
important person in his life he was so
moved by her death that he literally
bought the furniture from the hotel
where she had died bought a house
overlooking the cemetery where she's
buried furnished the house with with
that furniture and then spent half of
every year living in Avignon where he
would
is it the the grave several times a day
and the rest of the year of course he'd
spend back in England you know taking
care of the various responsibilities
he'd accumulated in the meantime what
was her name
Harriet Hardy Taylor when he met her she
was married to someone else and was
already the mother of three children you
say that he was 25 though and she was 23
exactly yes she had married at the age
of 18 to mr. Taylor who was a prosperous
businessman and they were members of the
Unitarian community in England at the
time and had very close association with
utilitarians you might say these were
the rising middle classes professional
commercial people who couldn't identify
with it with the Church of England and
so they would join the nonconformist
sexes so that would be things like
Methodism unitarianism they had rather
advanced views for their for their time
Mill was introduced to her at a dinner
gathering immediately captivated by her
and it was apparent to everybody else
that the feeling was mutual and the
question then was what in what direction
this relationship was was going to go
they started out as friends they work
together on a magazine she was very
interested in the same kinds of ideas
that mill held and that one point they
began to discuss what ideal marriage was
because of something very much discussed
at the time and that led inevitably to
questions or what about your marriage
and and before they knew it they had to
reveal to each other that they had
fallen very much in love and the
question now was how to maneuver in a
world where that was far more difficult
to do than it is today keep in mind that
in Victorian Britain children were
actually considered property of their
father in the case of divorce which was
absolutely devastating socially for
women the children were retained by by
the father and of course as you know
there's a vast literature written in
19th century about women who run off
with their lovers Anna Karenina comes to
mind and others so there's a strong
presumption against there having any
of serious relationship Mills family and
his friends are all against that in a
sense the the entire world it seemed at
times with one exception his friend
thomas carlyle conspired to convince him
that he should break off the
relationship and of course Harriet
Taylor was under the same kind of
pressure from her husband she was quite
honest with him and expressed to him
what her feelings were for a mill they
tried to handle it in a variety of ways
and in the end the problem was solved by
Harriet herself she made it clear to her
husband and to John Stuart Mill that she
was going to maintain both relationships
but without any kind of sexual conduct
so for approximately the next 15 years
mill and Harriet were allowed to have a
public life together they went to
museums and that the public lectures her
husband that is mrs. Taylor's husband
provided her with a cottage in the
country where they could meet
he even conveniently went to his club
for dinner two nights a week so that
mill could join Harriet for dinner at
the house at which they were now living
so it was a kind of remarkable a
relationship amongst the three both men
no doubt thought that this was a
temporary phenomenon and would soon be
terminated and then of course it went on
and on and they found that it couldn't
be terminated until mr. Taylor himself
died so this became a kind of scandal to
the Victorian society because it was
clear what the relationship was between
mill and inherit that they they very
much loved each other they worked
together and on projects she became an
essential part of his life but they went
out of their way to trying to maintain
the appearance and not just the
appearance but but the substance of
propriety to the best of my knowledge
despite all the gossip that existed at
the time I'm convinced that they they
never consummated their relationship
sexually until after they were married
and this by the way is not an unusual
theme in the 19th century I know that
most people would be skeptical about
something if you if you mentioned that
to them today but there were none
famous people who had relationships of
this kind or who were willing to
contemplate relationships of this kind
and so it was something that had to do
also with the the way in which men and
women were evolving and and how we were
coming to understand how they interacted
with each other and in that sense the
relationship between Mill and Harriet is
a sort of microcosm of all the evolving
changes and and to some extent I would
argue maybe to a very large extent the
paradigm of what a romantic relationship
is and I'm not using the word romantic
in a sort of trite sense it had a very
very specific meaning in in the
nineteenth century and you see this in
the novels of Jane Austen I think that's
probably the best example to given and
all the subsequent literature and it's
the notion that men and women can be
equals that they can be friends as
equals that they can bring out the best
in each other
that they can literally share their
lives and have a kind of intimacy that
was literally inconceivable in any
previous period in the history of the
world and I think that's true I think
that Mill and Harriet exemplified that
relationship I think that the kinds of
changes that were sort of introduced by
changes in the economy and politics and
culture continue to go on I would would
maintain it we're still in the process
of trying to define the relationship
between men and men and women but this
is an early example of the attempt to do
that against the backdrop that was
incredibly oppressive and difficult for
them they they exhibited a lot of
courage and I think to some extent that
reflected how much they really loved
each other and how valuable that
relationship was to both of them you
talked a lot about Harriet his wife in
the book but you also talk and quote a
lot from the autobiography so I went out
to try and find it in the bookstores
couldn't then I went on the Internet
googled in John Stuart Mill right within
a minute had the entire autobiography
online that I could read why is it so
easy you mean to get things on the
internet or read the old I mean I was
just surprised soon it's not a copyright
and all that but can you buy the
autobiography
for sure it's it's so it's it's
available usually it's not particularly
long so it's usually included in lots of
collections of of Mills work so someone
will put together an anthology of a few
of his famous essays and we'll also
include the autobiography it's it's
really a classic and people have who
have never read anything else that mill
has written have actually read the
autobiography and get a kind of sense of
of what his life was I must say is
someone trying to write a biography of
mill it's somewhat daunting to to
realize that he's already written the
classic on his life and and all you can
do is attempt to to capture a few things
and to provide a larger context but the
autobiography is important for several
other reasons autobiographies quite
literally didn't exist prior to the
beginning of the 19th century I mean
there are some works that are
occasionally classified as all around
autobiographies it's not really an order
of ography come into existence pretty
much the same time a novel does and it
serves the same purpose when we read a
novel from the end of the 18th century
to the present or if we read an
autobiography we not only want to know
the details about somebody's life it's
not sort of as if we're gossiping or
engaging in a kind of voyeurism what we
want to see is how that person comes to
understand who he or she is how they
begin to define themselves and become
the people that they are and that's what
Mills autobiography was intended to to
do it's not an exercise in egotism it's
not as if he decided that somehow he was
a great man and that people would want
to know all the details of his life he's
very careful about what he includes and
what he doesn't it's primarily a story
of how he comes to think the way he does
and who the people are who who helped
him to make the various transitions in
his life and in that respect he is kind
of mirroring in his own life what is
actually going on in the 19th century
because the 19th century is also the age
when we begin to get museums there are
no museums prior to the 19th century its
19th century that takes history and time
seriously it's when we come to
understand ourselves as historical
beings I am Who I am through time I make
my life I make my life through time and
he began to see the whole the history
of ideas from that that point of view to
think is not merely to have some insight
into an objective reality that exists
outside of us that you can give a kind
of final and definitive formulation of
the truth you have to see yourself as
inheriting problems from the past trying
to understand what you've inherited how
that applies to the world in which you
live to add to it if you can to to some
extent and then pass this on to others
without any presumption that it's
necessarily going to go one direction or
another by the way you mentioned the
autobiography started in the early 1800s
what was the date do you remember and
you know who the first plus I think
mentions the term autobiography I think
around 1809 and I don't know which
particular can't recall which particular
book he had in mind as the first things
about the first novel ah that's always
something that that people argue about
my choice is is a work by Benjamin
constant called a Dolph a DOL Phe which
happens to be a love story so it's not
unusual that if you want to single out
of work as an example of the first
modern novel that comes to mind because
it's the story of how someone finds out
who he is in his relationship a man in
his relationship with women he comes to
understand himself as a result of his
interaction with it I want to ask you
about his start in life but did very
quickly yes the major works that people
would recognize that he wrote that are
still out there
perhaps the most important and I think
the most enduring thing he ever wrote is
the essay of Liberty and I mention that
because that was the name of its on
Libya on liberty exactly and it's really
a defense of the idea of the importance
of individual autonomy and that we
should have a culture that respects and
promotes everybody's opportunity to
become who they want to be regardless of
whether they're geniuses or the most
ordinary kind of folk a second one a
second one would be in Mont to my mind
the principles of political economy
that's the work he wrote on economics
which became the standard textbook for
the last half of the 19th century until
it was succeeded at least in the field
of economics by far more technical works
so if one who's interested in technical
economics one wouldn't go back and read
Mills principles of political economy
but I think it's worth reading because
all the problems that we still deal with
in terms of Commerce and business and
economics and how this impacts the lives
of people those issues I think getters
still get a very fresh treatment they
are in in mill a third one a third one
I'd say the Autobiography because again
you get some notion of how a person
lives through a particular period of
time how they try to understand
themselves how they try to understand
the time they live in it is guys his
relationship with Harriet Taylor during
this oh sure the autobiography has a
kind of official discussion I say
official because she helped him to edit
it as well so anything that appears in
the autobiography except for the last
section which she wrote after she died
she agreed with what he said about their
relationship and it's quite laudatory we
one might say there's a great deal of
hyperbole in there but I say that
reflects something the depth of his
feeling it also was the kind of style of
the time the book logic
yeah the logic has some technical things
that are still of interest to
specialists in the field but I wouldn't
think that the ordinary person would
have would have much of an interest in
that except maybe the last section of
utilitarianism utilitarianism
unfortunately has become a kind of
textbook which and in my judgment is so
misunderstood because it's that's turned
into a sort of cardboard caricature of
Mills views and his read independent of
his other stuff but I think it gives to
a very large extent a distorted
conception of what he believed you say
that he was an early advocate of women's
suffrage and there's a book that he
wrote about it yes what does that come
yeah the subjection of women that was a
subject on which he wrote for for many
years off and on in the circles in which
he moved it was always thought that the
the women should be emancipated
that the relationships between men and
women would be radically transformed if
women had full political and economic
equality and it is a classic of its time
and what time did he write well he
finished writing it in 1861 but he
didn't publish it until 1869
because he was always very wary of the
kind of reception the book was going to
get so he he was careful to time the
publication to achieve what he thought
was its maximal effect what were women's
rights and Great Britain at that time um
next to nothing women could not own
their own property they could not have
any kind of custody rights in their in
their children they were excluded from
the universities from pursuing advanced
degrees and there was still a very
traditional view that a place of woman
was in a home as a homemaker
at the head of state was a woman yes
that was always one of the great ironies
of the time the other great irony is
that Queen Victoria herself was opposed
to extending the right to vote to which
women but I guess is the monarch who has
all of those privileges you might think
differently about wanting to share those
privileges with others when did they
abolish slavery in Britain of 1835 and
the utilitarians and the Unitarians were
very much behind the anti-slavery
movement in England that was a very big
point for them the Unitarians for
religious reasons the utilitarians made
a kind of economic argument that slavery
in fact was counterproductive
economically and that also color to some
extent Mills view of the American Civil
War because during the American Civil
War unlike most people in Britain he
took the side of the north
most the people of England at the time
tended to identify with with the South
when was he a member of parliament from
1865 or 1867 to 1869 he served winter
night right after them yeah he died
shortly thereafter he was not re-elected
to to Parliament but uh and then he had
just a few years after and he spent that
time primarily engaged in correspondence
and cleaning up some works which were
eventually published posthumously namely
his critique of socialism and and a few
other things he met Harriet at age 25
what year how was he when he married her
oh he married her in 1850
so he was 45 at the time and how many
years were they married they were buried
seven years before before she died so
actually they spent more time unmarried
than they spent married and then the
health thing yes Harriet Taylor died of
consumption or tuberculosis which was
the great scourge of the 19th century in
fact it had a significant part to play
in Mills life his father died of
tuberculosis two of his brothers died of
tuberculosis his best friend sterling
died of tuberculosis in fact if you go
through the list of all the people who
died from tuberculosis in 19th century
it's a kind of who's who of authors and
and and famous people the they really
did not know that it was a contagious
disease that that at that time Mill
himself contracted tuberculosis and
during the 1850s shortly after his
marriage to Harriet he and Harriet were
convinced that they were both dying and
didn't have much time to live and this
sort of dictated their lifestyle at the
time one of the things that Mill did was
to search for a cure and he found a
doctor who promoted the idea that
blowing into the to a trumpet would
actually help you it turned out that it
did because the blowing into a trumpet
strengthens your lungs and therefore
does help your lung sort of fight off
the tuberculous that are that are
connected with with tuberculosis so he
managed to survive his bout with with
tuberculosis unfortunately his wife
didn't what's the story of his back
wrenching that led to eyesight problems
ah there are there are a lot of myths
associated with that but he he used
unlike people today he would walk to
work which which meant a traversing of
London's parks as we know them and while
walking through one of those parks that
he tripped over a brick and hide in Hyde
Park right I hurt his back and they had
to put some kind of plaster on the back
I guess in order to get heat to go there
to help with the pain and at one point
he removed it and touched his eye and
was temporarily blind as a result of it
but they didn't it didn't last for very
long you said a thing ARS belladonna
yeah elastic yeah
the blaster plasti right and but
belladonna was also used for for other
purposes as well yeah but it was it was
in it was in the plaster in the sort of
SAP that they that they put on something
like a large bandage to wrap around
people to bring heat to that particular
part of the what I did is I said for the
recipe well it didn't it didn't really
affect it all that badly but he did
develop a tick in one of his eyes but
that was much earlier than that and that
had nothing to do with this particular
incident but was the tick from well
people claimed that the tick had
something to do with his relationship
with his father
but the tick started long before that
and I don't think it had anything to do
with that and I don't think we really
have any clear indication of what the
origin of the tick was he started
complaining about eye problems in the
early 1830s so long before there were
any events that could be connected with
it I'm mixing this up baby yes did he
develop a limp for the rest of it first
oh no he didn't but Harriet did in fact
starting in her early thirties Harriet
had a carriage accident and developed a
number of medical problems she would
have a attacks of neurons ax was was
temporarily crippled and unable to walk
and then she would would come out of it
and one of the things she did to help
herself during this period was to take
laudanum which is a kind of opium
derivative and the course is all kinds
of speculation about what effect this
might have had on her and on her
relationship with no but I've not
detected any influence of love that she
was 43 when they got married I assumed
the day Arab children no they did not
and I think that they didn't well for
several reasons one I think it would it
would have been impossible physically
because of her condition that I'm her
medical problems and the other this is a
perhaps a bit speculative mill and
Harriet were convinced that one of the
great problems of members of lower-class
is that they had too many children we
tend to see this as countries move from
an agricultural economy to an industrial
economy families begin to grow smaller
but in the beginning that's not the case
and so you get workers with large
numbers of children and then they're
thrown out of work and are unable to
support their families and this creates
all kinds of
social problems so Mel and Harriet
thought that if they could encourage
people to have fewer children to and to
engage either in abstinence or some form
of birth control natural or otherwise
that this would have a very positive
effect and I think to some extent they
tried to mirror that in their lives or
at least create the impression that sex
sexual abstinence and sexual
self-control was within the realm of the
possible and they did this during a time
when it was very very difficult to
defend that sort of that sort of you in
fact Mill became the butt of a number of
jokes he was a believed to be under
sexed so the presumption at the time was
that a vigorous male would naturally
want to engage in a great deal of sexual
activity the idea that you could
actually control your body and exercise
self-control would have been considered
too unnatural even by one of Mills early
biographers you paint a picture of them
that when they got married of living a
quiet reclusive life right where yeah
they took a house in Blackheath which is
in the northern part of London milk
continued to work during the 1850s at
India house which was his primary
occupation they thought that when mr.
Taylor died they were married that this
would be the end of all the social
problems that they had experienced but
quite the contrary on their marriage
actually made things more complicated
for them all the people who had gossiped
about their relationship before mr.
Taylor died could now point to them and
say you see they must have been doing
something wrong because now now they're
married Mills family was not
particularly receptive to his to his
marrying Harry and I think to some
extent that reflected the fact that he
would no longer be primarily responsible
for taking care of him so they were
concerned about the loss of his interest
and affection he also made it rather
difficult for people to come up and
congratulate him on his marriage since
he had been pretending for the previous
I don't know how many years that this
was just an acquaintance ship etc so all
all of a sudden one day we're supposed
to stop pretending that the relationship
is not going on and now it's okay for it
to go on so between the the
embarrassment they suffered and their
inability to to cope with that in
Victorian society at the time and their
concern that they were both dying and
they thought they had a mission and
their mission was somehow to pass along
but they considered to be important
crews they became quite reclusive in the
1850s and when mill was not working at
india house he was spending all of his
time preparing a number of famous works
that he would publish later and the
Herod was very much involved in that he
said that he wrote a draft of the work
and then would go back and write an
entire draft right yeah he wrote at
least two versions comparing suffering
or everything that he ever did he he did
this for a strange sort of reason in the
beginning very early in his life he was
asked to edit the works of Bentham a
very great 19th century British
philosopher who played it an important
role in Mills early life saying Ben yeah
yeah Bentham and the Jeremy Bentham the
original if you like utilitarian close
friend of his father a man vitally
involved in the social reform of his
time Bentham was a terrible writer and
to this day they're still trying to
straighten out his writings that's
called the Bentham project and people
expect it to go on for centuries or so
it seems and Mill had to put together
what Bentham said in different works and
try to make some kind of coherence out
of it from that he got the idea that he
himself should write several drafts and
then combine the two so it's as if he
were rethinking what his views were and
he didn't want to be influenced by his
original formulation of it and then he
would bring those two things together so
for Mill the editing of his work was
very important it was not only
self-conscious of himself as a stylist
but he was also very much concerned to
get the argument right they tried to
present it in the simple this most
simple in the clearest fashion that he
could who were just a couple of his
friends that we might know oh okay well
probably the the most important friend
he had
and what he was forming his his
conception of himself as a writer was
Thomas Carlyle and I would say that mill
and Carlisle were about as different as
you could possibly be in terms of
personality and views Mill learned a
great deal from from Carlisle what they
both aspired to be and this is the sense
in which the ultimately they became
competitors they both wanted to be the
conscience of their time except that
what that meant was very different to to
each of the mill was that was the was
the conscience of his time but from a
radical point of view and Carlisle was
the conscience of his time but really
from an ultraconservative one might
almost say reactionary have you been to
the graveside in heaven your honor the
house that he lived in oh sure yeah in
fact I spend a good deal of my vacation
time and France and I always make a
point of visiting the the site it would
still be difficult to describe for
people why repeat visits somehow inspire
me but I can't mention that in the 19th
century after the death of the Mills
visiting the grave became something that
Victorians did when they when they did
their sort of grand tour of that it's a
house still there yeah the house is
still there is it open to the public
no it's not open to the public at all
but you can go to the you can go to the
graveside I just walk in and there's a
caretaker who will direct you to to the
grave it's it's it's beautiful it's
peaceful in a way in which I never would
have understood as a young man that that
a cemetery could actually be a peaceful
delightful place to be how about his
home in London is that a music no it
some of the buildings exist but they're
but they're no longer places that would
be considered was in fact the British
the end of the 19th century after his
death weren't quite sure what to make of
Mill there was going with some talk of
erecting a plaque in his honor in
Westminster Abbey which would have been
the natural place to do it but there was
so much opposition because he advantage
to step on the toes of an awful lot of
people what there is is a statue in a
small park along the along the Thames
that's a little it's a bit of a trouble
too to kind of find it but it can be
found and it's it's a beautiful statue
did he know Tocqueville he did not meet
Tocqueville except for once and this was
after you'd read Tocqueville but he was
very much influenced by Tocqueville
tocqueville's writings not only gave him
an insight into America which were very
important it was very important for a
meal because he switched his his model
of what the future was from France to to
America but I think he he considered
Tocqueville the the great historian of
his time the the model of what it would
mean to write or to understand the
culture to give some account of what the
essence of a culture was and what what
the conflicts were in that culture and
what the future of directions and
possibilities worse was a kind of
writing he had not previously come
across you say his parents had nine
children yes did he was he close to him
at all yo he was very close to several
of his of his younger brothers however
was he and they in there he was the
oldest in fact his he had the the
benefit if you want to call it that of
his father's undivided attention
his father was primarily responsible for
educating at home and then mill was
responsible for educating the other
members of the family so into his early
30s he literally had to spend several
hours every day educating his younger
sisters and and brothers they all of
course admired him and looked up to him
none of them quite achieved the kind of
thing that he did when did his mother
die and what was his relationship with
her his mother died in in the eighteen
in the 1850s he was never very close to
his mother in fact the most remarkable
thing about his autobiography the
published version of his autobiography
is that his mother is not mentioned now
it would seem rather strange to write an
autobiography and that you don't mention
your mother there was a passage in which
he described his mother in an earlier
draft of the autobiography and it's not
a beautiful picture that he that he
paints and Harriet Taylor of the sake of
propriety had him removed that that
particular passage essentially he he had
the same view of his mother that his
father did he was somewhat contemptuous
of his mother he didn't think that she
was very smart he didn't think that she
had much strength
of character and probably would have
considered her one of those genteel
useless women that some people in the
18th and 19th century used to admire I
think probably the root of it was he
would have wanted a strong loving mother
to protect him from time to time from
his overbearing father and that was and
that wasn't there and so he simply took
over the care of his mother after his
father died and the other members of his
his family and I think he resented the
kind of time he had to spend on that
and later he thought when he when he
decided to marry Harriet that his family
was not positively respond responsive in
the way that he would have wished and he
took great umbrage at that and that just
sort of made the split even worse so he
would be a dutiful son and all the
things that he had to do but it was a
responsibility rather than an act of
love or charity in his how many years
did he work at India house and what was
yeah he started working at India house
when he was when he was 17 in the house
started out as a commercial venture for
the economic development of India but by
the time mill went to work God in the
house it was it was a sort of quasi
autonomous corporation simply a
bureaucratic enterprise that ruled that
ruled India for the British Empire it
gradually lost its Ed's commercial
dimension his father had been employed
but in the house and mill ended up
working there as well for a variety of
reasons that there really was no other
occupation for him to pursue given his
background and he had to work under his
father and if you were to describe the
work he did oh you might perhaps
analogize it to to being a pretty high
official maybe an Assistant Secretary of
State in charge of correspondence
between British officials in India and
British officials back home and in those
days it took months for a letter
actually to get from one place to to the
other so he earned his living doing that
every day he worked for them until the
corporation finally came to an end and
was dissolved in 1857 although he did
defend the validity of the in
of the institution for quite some time
and refused to serve on it when it would
simply became another government
bureaucracy he said he never went to
India that's the amazing thing his
father and he his father by the way
wrote a 10 volume history of India and
he and his father were primarily
responsible for the correspondence and
for making some important decisions
affecting the Government of India
neither one of them ever set foot in
India and to the best of my knowledge
neither one of them ever knew anyone who
was from from India but it said it says
something about about the time
nevertheless Mill had very enlightened
view he really thought it was the
responsibility of the of the British to
help India to become independent just as
he thought it was the responsibility of
every institution to help people to
become as independent as they possibly
could and he saw that as Britain's
responsibility
James Mill who was he James mill would
have been considered one of the most
important philosophers of the 19th
century if it hadn't been for the fact
that he was the father of John Stuart
Mill who later eclipsed him in
reputation he was a Scotsman who earned
his living originally as as a journalist
when he failed as a clergyman moved to
London and ended up working for India
house in order to support his large
family but perhaps the most important
thing to say about James mill
historically is that he was the leader
of the of the radical movement and what
that means is that these were members of
the middle class who realised that
Britain could no longer be a feudal
society not in the light of the growth
of Technology the Industrial Revolution
and that the and that the political
institutions had to change in retrospect
we would say that James mill had a
somewhat simplistic view of what kind of
political changes would would be
necessary but he had an enormous
influence up until the 1830s through not
as a member of parliament he could never
be a member of parliament but through
his connection with parliamentary
members and as a man who held together
all these thinkers who were critical of
British society at the time the other
thing to say about him is that he was
very much an eighteenth-century man
living
to the 19th century most of his
philosophical ideas where were based on
18th century views and to some extent
Mill had to spend most of his life
getting over some of those 18th century
views in his son believe in God I think
he did but it's a kind of God that most
people would have difficulty recognizing
I think for most of Mills life he did
not have a formal belief in God he was
he was very anti religious in the sense
of being opposed to religious
establishments I mean in his and his
time the Anglican Church was largely
defending the status quo he had been
brought up to some extent brought up
that's had to be carefully qualified as
a kind of Calvinist and it was a
Calvinism that that promoted the idea of
repression rather than self-development
so given his background he would have
been hostile to it but I think over the
years he changed his views it ultimately
came to believe in a kind of God and I
would describe it as unusual in this
sense he didn't believe that God was
omnipotent he thought that God was here
too maybe to lead the forces of good
against the forces of evil
a kind of manichaean view that the world
is divided between good and evil and
somehow it was our part to help this God
to to achieve these these purposes I I
think it's absolutely central to his
view that in other words if you work out
the logic of Mills thinking I don't see
how he could have avoided coming to
believe something like that not and I've
argued that in in the in the book I
think it's important he's also very
spiritual man even though he had no
official connection with with the
religious denomination what year did his
father die 1836 what impact did that
have on him great relief he had gone
through a mental crisis from roughly
1826 to 1830 what we would call an
identity crisis and a large part of that
crisis was I want to get out from under
my father's control I want to be my own
person at the same time he found he
began to fight to find that there are
all kinds of problems with his father's
philosophical views so how is he going
to achieve this what he did was
he reconciled himself in the following
way since he agreed with his father's
political program of reform but had a
very different idea of how one was to
understand that he submerged all of his
own views and largely pretended to agree
with his father and tried in very
indirect ways to present different
perspectives when his father died he did
not attend his father's funeral he
presumably was off recovering from one
of his own illnesses but I think it
would have been too painful for him to
have gone he respected his father but he
didn't really love him and now he felt
relieved that he could actually express
his own views and almost immediately
after his father's death he published an
essay on Bentham a full essay that he
had previously published under a
pseudonym in order to keep his father
from from being angry with him in which
he literally over wrote a devastating
critique of Bentham which in many ways
is a veiled criticism of his own of his
own father but it's it's an intellectual
critique not not a personal critique he
an enormous respect for his father he
really believed in what his father was
trying to do but he couldn't share the
sort of intellectual vision or the
larger vision of what it meant to be a
human being and that's that created
enormous problems for him
psychologically your own PhD is from
where it's in philosophy where Columbia
University in New York but I'm happy to
say that as a result of my association
with Liberty fund which we mentioned
earlier that I managed to get a liberal
education after I achieved the PhD and
that is by attending conferences on
subjects about which I knew very little
at the time whether it was economics or
our literature or our political theory
and it's this this is sort of education
everybody should have when one rarely
achieves what but your undergraduate
degree one that graduate degree was also
in in philosophy or I should mention in
passing the philosophy has now become a
kind of technical subject so the sort of
philosopher that mill was one who
actually addressed the major issues of
his day somebody who could communicate
with ordinary with the ordinary
intelligent public
in a way the kind of public that you
reach through this program the kind of
books that you that you present it would
be difficult to find very many
philosophers today who could write that
kind of book and your undergraduate
degrees from where Pitt University of
Pennsylvania in Philadelphia so we have
you being born in Pennsylvania yes now
teaching at Loyola and New Orleans right
and spent some time at City University
right now large part of my adult life
was spent in New York City yes this book
is published by Cambridge yes a British
publisher yes who who do you think who
did you write this for what kind of a
person okay I I wrote this for the kind
of public that mil was trying to reach
this may seem strange he believed that
there were a large number of highly
educated people who were not specialists
and that somehow or other it was part of
his job to remind them of what the
fundamental values were and their
civilization and I'm in a way trying to
revive that idea of what it means to be
a public intellectual the sort of thing
that mill practice at the end of his
life and I was hoping that through the
reading of this book people would would
come to see what what it meant to play
that kind of role and what and why
that's important and more important than
playing the role is finding the public
that that can be responsive that that is
interested in this sort of thing and so
to create a sort of intellectual public
that is interested in ideas the beyond
the superficial level how long it take
you to write it the last the last five
years we're spent almost exclusively on
this book but I had been writing bits
and pieces on mill for 20 years prior to
that and a book like this first printing
would have been how many copies I don't
know I must tell you I'm very
impractical when it comes to those
things I let the publisher worry about
all of that but I'm hoping well I'm sure
it's not enough copies now that I want
here you have another book you're
finding right yes the the next book I
want to write is called the business of
America
and what I hope it will be is an attempt
to capture the American soul I know this
sounds very presumptuous and what that
means for America both domestically and
internationally so it if you like in a
small way I'm trying to emulate for our
own culture what mill did for British
culture here's the cover of the book on
this picture how old was he he was in
his mid-30s when that picture was was
taken how tall was he
510 and what would he have sounded like
he had rather high pitched voice not not
a very deep one but people tended to
describe to describe him as a kind of
thinking steam engine a man always
speaking very logically and carefully
carefully choosing his words John Stuart
Mill is the name of the book a biography
Nicholas Capaldi our guest thank you
very much for joining us thank you Brian